but we begin tonight with this it is
time to stop funding the United Nations
the wh the wef get out of the climate
Paris climate Accords and all these
other globalist
organizations why are we supporting
these groups historically the UN for
example has been anti-American
anti-semitic the who was the propaganda
wing of China during covid and now a new
Israeli intelligence document spelling
out very disturbing allegations against
a dozen employees working for a UN
agency the
unrwa uh which by the way claims to
provide assistance to Palestinian
refugees now according to the document
well 12 employees took part in the
October 7th Hamas Terror attacks
including seven who stormed into Israeli
territory were allegedly responsible for
truly despicable acts and intelligence
shared with the United States estimates
that about 12 100 employees of this
agency have links to Hamas or the
Palestinian Islamic Jihad in light of
these allegations the US and many other
countries they have cut funding rightly
so to the agency which has sparked
outrage from the radical left even
congresswoman acasio Cortez is calling
for funding to be restored immediately
shocker as did Bernie Sanders who said
quote we cannot allow Millions to suffer
because of the alleged actions of 12
people echoing remarks from the White
House yesterday take a look let's not
impune the good work of a whole agency
uh because of the potential bad actions
here by a small number I am not
dismissing the seriousness of the
allegations against those employees and
whether there's going to be more that'll
be found hopefully the investigation
will uh will uh uh will give us more
insight all right here's the problem
this Administration is once again A Day
Late dollar short now since 2021 they
have funneled more than than one billion
of your tax dollars to this agency back
in 2018 former president Donald Trump he
caught he cut all us funding to the
unrwa and once again he's been proven
right now last night the New York Post
editorial board they stepped up and they
took it one little step further by
calling for the us to stop funding the
United Nations all together you know
what I completely agree it is time for
America to now take a stand stop being a
sucker Nation stop paying the bulk of
the freight meaning your tax money to
organizations that don't even like us
and basically side with our enemies and
that brings us to the country of Iran
Joe Biden your appeaser and chief is
about to make some of the most
consequential decisions of his
presidency there have now been at least
166 attacks on US forces in the Middle
East that's only since October 17th all
done by by Iranian proxies so the big
question is what is Joe Biden going to
do will it be a typical meaningless
response a pin prick like you know
striking an empty warehouse and claiming
Victory will the administration botch
the response Al together now according
to new reports officials are now worried
about large scale attacks on Americans
in the Middle East uh secretary blinkin
added this yesterday take a look I think
it's very important to note that this is
an
incredibly volatile time in the Middle
East um I would argue that we've not
seen a situation as as dangerous as the
one we're facing now across the region
since at least 1973 and arguably uh even
uh even before
that Americans uh Mr blinkin are already
under attack abroad this weekend we lost
three brave soldiers and 40 others plus
injured but still this White House says
there's no scheduled remarks addressing
the vile attack three American troops
are dead others injured uh isn't it time
we hear from the president but instead
of addressing the nation what what is
Joe doing today oh he spent the day
campaigning in Southern Florida he could
have come to visit me but before
departing the White House he offered
another tepid vague response take a
look responsible for the death of those
I
respons
we that's not a response the
administration's reaction to the deadly
uh attack this weekend has been
downright embarrassing yesterday press
secretary Karen Jean Pierre offered
these very very bizarre comments take a
look at this our deepest condolences go
out and our heartfelt condolences go out
to the families uh who lost uh three
three Brave uh three Brave uh three
Brave of three folks who are who are
military folks who are brave who are
always fighting who are fighting on
behalf and of uh this administration of
the American people obviously more so
more
importantly three
folks what you just heard is an utter
embarrassment a disgrace to those
soldiers that died and frankly their
families they did not die fighting for
this Administration they died because of
this administration's weakness and
incompetence that's what happened here
and the fact that they have allowed
attack after attack after attack to go
unanswered meanwhile Biden is being
slammed after John Kirby refused to say
whether or not he would attend uh the
dignified transfer at do Air Force Base
but maybe that's for the better you may
recall the last time he was there there
for a dignified transfer remember the 13
marines that died during his disastrous
Afghanistan withdrawal yeah remember Joe
is pretty bored he was checking his
watch every two seconds just in case you
don't remember take a
look well apparently we don't have that
cut I'm sorry about that all right now
I'm not advocating for foreign conflict
I want to be very clear here however let
me be very clear no one person no
country on this Earth gets away or has
the right to kill Andor injure Americans
abroad now uh if they attack you aund
nearly 200 times yes that does warrant a
fierce response one proportional to what
it is they've been up to if Joe Biden
wants to show the world that he's
serious well maybe he wants to take out
Iran's refineries that is the main
source of the Iranian mulla's money it's
oil hit them where it hurts they are
fast also reproaching the ability to
produce nuclear weapons and according to
an iaea report last month they have
undone the the slowdown in enrichment of
uranium to near weapons grade but they
face no consequences from europees or in
Chief Joe Biden turned a blind eye to
nearly 200 attacks against our military
in Iraq and Syria leading up to what
happened this past weekend he spent the
better part of his president
sucking up to Iran and helping the
Iranian mullers get rich now between
reportedly turning a blind eye to their
oil sales you know tens and tens and
tens of billions of dollars for the
mullers to forment more terror and and
and Aid in a bet in Terror Wars and and
fighting proxy wars remember none of
this happened under Donald Trump Joel
offered them also six billion doll The
Ransom payment for a prisoner swap and
then extended a waiver that allowed them
to take 10 billion from Iraq for
electricity sales in other words this
Administration has frankly opted for a
policy of ass-kissing appeasement and
sadly the chaos the destruction uh
carried out by Iranian proxies was
predictable this was all predictable how
many times do you have to get attacked
before and your and your troops targeted
before you realize uh one of these
attacks is going to kill people this
would never have happened if Joe Biden
dealt with the nearly 200 previous
attacks hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else